impossible de les rater
tous les jours sur le bord du parcours
c'est 300 points car attendent lilian
jégou le coureur préféré de jean yves
chantal et brigitte des heures de
patience pour quelques secondes
d'encouragement topiaires lilian jégou
s'est fait désirer
l'étape de montagne lui a été fatal et
c'est dans la voiture de son équipe à
ses supporters le voit pas déçu mais pas
résigné à l'est les trois couples
repartent aussi sec arrêt prévu quelque
part entre que j'avais marseille voire
au delà
pour pouvoir redescendre sur les 942 on
a étudié le parcours avant de façon à ne
pas perdre de temps vous rattraper après
la prochaine étape
pourquoi que c'est important ça ne veut
pas perdre de temps et bien pourrait
avoir des meilleures places et c'est
parti pour deux cents kilomètres chaque
fois c'est toujours qu'il va dire
le tour de france version portugal 6,5
me tue les maîtres des paysages sans
cesse renouvelé c'est la deuxième fois
que j'arrive le fait ces masses on a
pris trois semaines de vacances même
bien de vélo et du combat ont voyagé en
même temps on voit du pays on rencontre
des gens là on a rencontré des amis ça
fait quatre jours et il a sympathisé des
gens contre commandes connaissait pas
qu'on avait jamais on a sympathisé et
puis ça y est on va faire le tout
ensemble
comme chaque soir ils étaient joints et
le parcours de l'étape suivant le plus
dur reste à faire trouver un bon
emplacement tous les gosses de la place
courroye
drapeaux en place le campement est
maintenant prêt à la santé numéro
malheureusement abandonné où nous avons
une pensée pour lilian jégou
même si tous ont décidé dé suivre
christophe moreau toujours en course